she's been picked for a record at sixth
at a World Cup but how much do you know
about Brazil star Mata well her full
name is Mata Vieira de Silva and she's
widely considered the greatest female
footballer ever my taste the queen why
taste the icon and just to be around her
is uh contagious Marta has played in
five straight World Cups from 2003 to
2019 and despite injury concerns
Brazil's coach has decided to take her
to this year's tournament in Australia
and New Zealand she is generous and she
has a lot of energy worshiping starting
to line up
I don't know Martin plays her Club
football for the Orlando pride in the
United States she's Brazil's record
scorer with 115 goals and was the first
player male or female to score at five
World Cups she's also found the net at
five Olympics and be named World Player
of the Year six times certainly one of
the main contributors to the growth of
women's football over the last two
decades she does not dominate the game
today as much she is a little bit older
not as fast and the development of
women's game is so fast now so we have a
lot of good players I think it will be
hard for any player to dominate as much
as Marta did for all her success martyr
has never won the World Cup finishing as
a runner-up in 2007 and at 37 years old
this will likely be her last chance
foreign